and we are just getting a statement from
uh the study preparatory school and the
statement says we are profoundly shocked
by the tragic accident this morning and
devastated that has claimed the lives of
the life of one of our young pupils as
well as injuring several others our
thoughts are with the bereaved family
and with the families of those injured
at this terrible time it is still far
too soon to fully understand what
happened but we are well aware
of these significant impact uh this
Dreadful event will have on our pupils
and their families their welfare remains
our top priority and we will be doing
everything we can to support them
especially those who suffered injuries
uh now that a police investigation is
underway we will not be making any
further public statement for the time
being and would ask that the privacy of
our school Community is respected at
this upsetting time